more than 200 miles northwest of
mayfield recovery efforts will resume at
another workplace this too ripped apart
by the storm it's an amazon facility in
edwardsville illinois it's near st louis
that tornado killed at least six people
a seventh person was airlifted to a
hospital at least 45 people did survive
the collapse of this warehouse mo
lolangi is on the scene there and has
more on that story mulla good morning to
you
good morning gail the fire department
still working to clear debris from the
site which is just on the back end of
the building that you see behind me
there and they're still working with
amazon to make sure that all of the
employees who worked here are accounted
for and we spoke with one mother who
waited outside this facility for hours
on friday night waiting for word on her
son only to find out he didn't make it
he just had a really big heart he would
do anything for anybody carla cope's son
clay had been working as a contractor at
the edwardsville amazon facility for
nearly a year clay a navy veteran would
have turned 30 in two weeks
carla says she and clay spoke on the
phone she believes he used his final
moments to warn others to take shelter i
think he would help anybody
i wouldn't expect anything less of him
to go back and try to help people to get
to where they needed to be partially
because of his military training and
partially just because that's who he was
a swath of tornadoes cut through at
least six states one of them tore into
the amazon warehouse in illinois
the roof caved in on both sides of the
facility where workers prepare orders
during the busy holiday season our
hearts are broken you know they said for
many of these folks they were their
friends their co-workers important
people in their lives and so we're going
to do everything we can you know to
support our employees make sure they
have access to all the services that
they need kelly nantel is an amazon
spokesperson when you have a tornado
that cuts right through the center of
the building it's a pretty devastating
you know force of nature and that's what
we had here it's a devastation carla
cope and her family know all too well
now taking care of clay's beloved dog
draco as they mourn i guess you do what
everybody else does you take it day by
day and
try to figure out how you live without
them
now this amazon facility will remain
closed for at least the next few days
amazon says they're waiting on first
responders to finish their work here at
the site and then the company will
determine the future of the building
tony
mola thank you very much